ああああああ
8こんにちははじめ社長です
なおそう皆さんシーブリーズアップしてるからまぁ僕もね中学校のときはよくお世話
だったんだけども言えば部活とかねスポーツをしているとやっぱ汗をかくんではその時
こう制汗剤とかで使ってたシーブリーズって商品があるんだけども
今回ですねシーブリーズのシリーズ no 8ボディーシャンプーがあるんですけど
そのシーブリーズのスーパークールポピー#者
ありませんこちら
[音楽]
俺が中学には欲しいぶりっ子してるやつはもう当たったんだよってくれちょっと多さに
よっては数分りつさんありがとうございます
そのシービーズのスーパークールボディ# jazz からでもう
かなスーパークールボディシャンプーを使うと真夏の環境でも涼しく感じるという
ちょっと画期的なアイテムらしいよねことでは
時代に説明してほしいブリーザ100年も続いている歴史的
いいなブランドだよ1902名から実はシールリズは始まっているのかよ
今回ですでもスーパークールボディシャンプーかですねその真夏の緩急でもこれを使っ
たらで涼しく感じるらしいんで
[音楽]
どーなろう朝霞でまだちょっと基本的にはそんなにまっすぐない今日この頃
そこで僕は考えたいっそうのことは僕自身で真夏の3強を作り出そう
ちょっとまだ真夏の季節じゃないんで今日はですねこちらのヘアを作ったんだんっては
夏ぐらいのキューバで木幹はげんします
でそこで俺らの中学校とそのように後年ベンツをし
エイ
アパ助っ人のつぼみね部活をしてもう超汗かいてもその時部おかず感じますまずで運動
している急もまずアジア部実を草履運動して僕はどんな気持ちなのか
イヤな気持ちですよねいやだけます今熱い気持ちになるんですけども
その後のセブシャワーを浴びていきますそのシャワーを浴びる時にスーパークール
ボディ#を使ってまたこの真夏の環境に残っ
その時俺はどう感じるか使う前と使った後の感じよね比較してみようと思います
行くぜっ2色 max 御土産
図1取ってみても暖房が効き出してるでもちょっと環境があったかくなってきています
ではあったままでし場所も著
僕は熱々のうどんを作っていきます
[音楽]
あっつば何度も真夏配管を思い出すよ
熱々と辛いチャンネルを入れた有働を持ってきました
愛という実験スタートでございます good しまくった手熱いもなくてめっちゃ汗
かいて苦しい状態
そうスーパーというのを使った後を比較してみようと思います
すべっすべ5分5
[音楽]
ch
チャーはれたきついで
アツェえっ志布志塗って
ていません
てるぞ
まず足りねぇいいぞ lolo lolo
1巻
[音楽]
通常
を見なさい前回でございます
これだけがせいただけましたーーー
はいこんなもんでした夏のスポーツの花つってもまぁ俺はずっとバスケ部だったら夏
作り下がってる
はい友会君たちを持っただろう俺がええな汗臭いと思うかだろ
いいな本当はいつもならこの汗をかいた存在だもきっと任せくさいです
金成ボクはこの運動する前にシーブリーズの幸便シャンプー
クーラーなんていうことだとこちらですねこちらの書
教員が使っていたので副作ないんですこれで事前に体を嵐おくことで汗のニオイを
しっかり抑えてすっきり爽快感の持続するボディシャンプーなのでこれよね運動と冠水
していない
阿川の強くと汗を教育しないとなので僕は度はいえには生かしてますただけですね
cvd のスーパーという posy シャツを掴んで体を洗っていきます寸前に何か
はガセが嫌だ
終わっていまーす
ああああああ
アンマンへ告げすげーあんまり暑いって感じナイス
でさっきと全然違うすごい全然違いの殺気立っていえスーパークールは結構効き目が
ありました
体でなく進んだよ触れる空気がラスク感じないっていうか
スーパークールを使った後に扇風機を使うとはなんか pot
涼しいみたいな寒いくらい涼しい聞いたんでしょうね
あってみますとを数周する寒い配球で c please のスーパークール
ポジションぷとジュリーズボディーシャンプークール&デオドラントでございました
を手書きする前にクーラーと手を取らんとで体を洗って手足て書いて暑いところから
帰ってきたりしたらスーパークールボディションってから時ですこの2つあれがたる夏
は結構いける気がします
深さしている君とがたくさん動いたりしなきゃいけない人とかぜひ cba ずお試し
ください
夏には涼しいんだけど運動しておら疲れちゃっては黙ってしゃべり杖
夏はおりキョウジャー
[音楽]